this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks everyone this is episode five of
the Cornell Turf show this year uh
excited to have our guest on today you
uh those who have watched or listened to
the show will remember Dr Sean Askew
from Virginia Tech uh he's joining us on
vacation in his car today from a
putt-putt golf course so Frank we've
made it big time we can get Sean on his
vacation uh in a car to join us and talk
about Turf so we're excited to have Sean
on the show today uh but but Frank I'll
throw it out to you as our West Coast
correspondent today coming from Oregon a
couple time zones over uh Frank how you
doing this morning what do you got
planned I'm doing good Carl trying to
get on Eastern time yeah I was out here
uh visiting with some of the folks that
Oregon State University looking at uh
some of their annual Bluegrass stuff and
and walking around some golf courses uh
looking at some absolutely spectacular
annual Bluegrass if you want to see
annual Bluegrass uh this is definitely
the part of the world and of course
driving through the Willamette dammit
Valley uh you know you're in the grass
seed capital of the world out here so
it's been a great visit but let's get
started because everybody's making their
first cuts
um and everybody's excited about that
first sharp line that they can make
hoping they can keep it up uh throughout
the whole season but I think for those
of us that have worked in this business
a really long time there's something
that signifies the growing season a lot
of people were tweeting about the
various first Cuts uh many uh obviously
down uh where Sean is have been cutting
already but but for now
um we're just getting going now you know
again dogs is always a great way to
start when you're looking for a smile or
or really uh want to break your heart a
little bit uh you know there's a new guy
joining the team uh on the left and Mark
Pryor just lost uh his uh his Goose
Chaser Sadie uh recently marks a golf
course superintendent and I know well
former golf course superintendent that I
know up in Ontario Canada and you know a
lot of people uh tweet about these
things uh this is again one of those
areas I love seeing and Golf Course
superintendents uh getting the share now
uh last week we didn't have the show we
were at janandasas for the walk and talk
it's hard to believe that was already a
week ago and this is what it looked like
uh completely buried in snow and the
great reveal right looking under these
uh these were the permeable covers
because the impermeable covers have had
already been taken off so I had a great
discussion about uh a poo cover system
they caught they cover all 22 greens out
there it's really a fascinating
operation and Chris is passing it off to
Stephen but you know the big reveal
right we got to see the Green Grass and
then you know this whole deal right this
somebody's gonna find out who this
person is and there's going to be Health
to pay uh this Anonymous Augusta in the
uh in honor of the Masters which I hear
is going to get some really crappy
weather uh this past week this coming
weekend so you know if it gets it's
going to be cool so that and cool and
wet
so it could be a very interesting week
but again you know the big reveal so
Carl as I pass it back to you we got a
big reveal today let's see let's hear
about it yeah Frank that's beautiful
transition big reveal for us uh we we've
uh for again people who've watched and
listened to the show for a while you'll
recognize this poster on the left this
golf course sustainability practices
poster right we've been talking about
pars Bernie's Eagles for a couple years
we did the segments right bmps tips of
the day and the last year we've spent uh
really sort of curating a Next Level
resource a companion document to that
poster and that's what we're calling a
golf course sustainability handbook so
we just released that online yesterday
there's a QR code up here for those
watching on the screen yeah uh and I'll
send it I'll send a link in the chat as
well
um but really Frank what we've done with
this is go into a next layer of detail
so we really talk about each practice we
pull it out give it its own page uh we
we talk about why it's important and we
really sort of tried to make this quick
you know bullet points really easy to
read right you'll see a lot of space on
the screen we worked with graphic
designers me has been great sort of
laying these Pages out to look nice uh
we've got icons there that indicate the
seasonality right so when should we do a
practice spring summer fall or winter
and then one of the things we were very
intentional about intentional about
Frank was addressing some of the hurdles
or the barriers to adoption so when we
went out and surveyed a bunch of
superintendents uh really three years
ago now uh something like for example
soil moisture meter is what we've got up
on the screen here that panel uh we
heard from them hey there's a couple you
know things that uh that they told us
hey here's why I don't do this it's it
cost a little bit and hey I can irrigate
perfectly fine without a soil moisture
meter so we really tried to acknowledge
that throughout the handbook and we say
hey we understand you can be a great
waterer right a great irrigator without
a soil moisture meter but try and try
and talk about some of the other
benefits right if you've got two or
three people going out and hand watering
on greens they're going to see things
differently they're going to react to
things differently one person may see a
little bit of drought and oh they're
going to hammer it for 10 minutes
another person might say hey we're good
for the rest of the day so a moisture
meter and here's you know what we're
saying in this Pro tip is hey that gives
you a way to normalize all that right
and make sure you're consistent across
the property even between people
um so when we talk about you know who
who this document is for right for the
superintendent you can get that
awareness you can learn sort of
understanding of each BMP why it's
important uh but we also think it can be
used by the staff right you can throw
this thing on your on your break room
right the lunch table people can flip
through it just like there's other
magazines out there and they can learn
some new things you know here's why
we're doing x y and C on the golf course
and why it's important uh and then maybe
it's important for the golfers in your
membership you can use it as a
communication tool
um so again some of the hurdles and
barriers to adoption things like long
grass areas cutting down on water and
fertilizer and the roughs right that's
those are always sort of barriers that
the golfers or the membership are
driving as a superintendent if you can
go and give this booklet hey Cornell and
the New York state p2i center hey
they're telling us maybe we should do it
this other way maybe that gets you over
the hump uh helps you reduce that
resource use and then the final part
Frank is keeping score right keeping
that metaphor of golf seeing how you
stock up right at the end of uh at the
end of the document is basically a slow
card right you mount your mark down how
many of these bmps you do and then you
can see where you stack up are you a BMP
beginner intermediate Advanced and again
we're acknowledging not everybody is
going to do all 34 bmps in here right we
didn't see that in our first survey
we're probably not going to see that in
simple uh you know in further surveys
but uh really sort of putting a number
to what you're doing is going to
motivate you just sort of internally hey
I did an 11 out of 34. and maybe there's
a couple more pars or birdies I can
knock off and not my score so we think
that might be a good motivational tool
and a way for you to sort of keep track
of your BMP progress so uh Frank we're
super excited to release this we're
going to be doing a lot of Outreach
extension we're going to send this
physically to all the Central and
Western New York courses so they'll have
a nice printed high quality document and
hopefully this creates a lot more
awareness and implementation as some of
these vfps yeah absolutely Carl just
just look it's some color here uh you
know one of the things that we learned
is we tried to make this simple right
and I'm you know it's not criticism of
the gcsa's facility guide
um but that's a laundry list I mean
you're gonna sit there for hours working
through that this is something you could
sit through uh and if you you know this
is a good first step to that right this
will give you get you into mindset see
what you're adopting we whittled a lot
of that down to the simplest things so
that's the first thing second is you
know this will stay funded the BEC gives
the money to the p2i people so less
people think the dec doesn't want to
partner with us I think this is really
important that we we demonstrate our
willingness to measure not just uh talk
to talk uh but walk the walk and Carl
right the next step is we're going to
come out now west of I-81 we're going to
survey another 45 golf courses and say
you know how'd you do here are you more
aware of you adopted these things uh
where are we going so we'll start that
pretty soon right yeah so we're going to
start that probably in late May
hopefully uh but we'll start going out
again random survey so really the idea
was you know we've done this Outreach
and education for a couple years uh is
there a measurable improvements in
certain bmps because we've created this
awareness and understanding so uh it'll
be interesting to look at those numbers
but we also understand again looking at
AG who's been doing this for a long time
it takes a long time it's a slow creep
right and so a lot of it's about
awareness first just being aware of
what's a BMP and why should I do that
exactly right all right great thanks
Carl appreciate that now listen we gotta
we got a great guest and it's going to
be a very Lively conversation so let me
get through some of the weather quick
west and south of the region was above
normal right it was warm uh down in
Virginia and all the way up in a buffalo
and then cool uh east of the Hudson
River and into New England uh below
normal to the north and to the east now
soils are starting to really warm up and
we're gonna you know a big shift is
coming based on our thing gaitano was
sticking his neck out this morning
during the conference call talking about
the weather really warming up in the
next couple of weeks and the models are
very much confirming this but right now
you're in the 40s if you're Upstate
you're in the 50s if you're downstate
and along the coast and it's been
actually pretty dry and Sean down by you
last month it actually has been pretty
looks like it's been pretty dry down by
you but wet to the western part of the
region certainly along uh the Great
Lakes but as I said earlier uh pretty
good confirmation that we're coming into
a pretty solid maybe two week period of
warm and dry weather you know art says
this is a ridge uh that's that's high
pressure that stuck over us now that's
you know really is a signal of the
changing climate as the gradient between
the Equator and the poles change the the
weather patterns get fixed and and they
create things like an atmospheric River
out west and uh at least a two-week
start of dry warm weather which means
soils are going to form as they start to
dry right they'll start to warm up a
little bit to a certain point and then
they'll really start to match air
temperature now the conversation of the
day which you've already started because
we took last week off has been about
annual Bluegrass uh seed head
suppression and we have really the guy
who sort of revolutionized the changing
of the way we think about it now from
our perspective historically we've gone
with Growing Degree Days uh through the
spring right there's various models we
have both the proxy and an Embark model
that we we keep on our forecast website
that takes the data that others have
done and the work that we have done and
it starts on a particular date and a lot
of people have used this model uh to
great success others use the growing the
gdd tracker this is Ron Calhoun's based
on Ron Calhoun's work many years ago out
at Michigan State that was looking at
these uh base 32 Growing Degree Days for
their work and they've just applied it
uh across the Northeast region as well
so some know there's slight variability
when it's considered to be ideal in your
head or behind but really oh and so as
we introduce Sean ask you Sean I will
congratulate you for
um winning the be being uh awarded as a
recognized as a fellow of the North Main
well but see you know you're talking to
somebody who that's the first
professional association I ever joined
uh when I was a master's candidate at
URI back in the mid 80s I used to go
with John Jack shits back then so to me
this is a really high honor there's you
know like I do some of these Regional
weed science societies like the southern
weed science Society is really strong I
mean it's it's as strong as the national
in some ways you you you're a fellow of
this organization you're in an elite
group of really good weed scientist so
listen here's the work we're talking
about you know that you ultimately
published where you started these winter
applications locking in that seed head
suppression which seemed to make the
spring applications uh a little bit less
important although still important uh to
make at least one many will say but some
people might just be using the fall and
not wanting to regulate in the spring
now this got taken out a little wider
right and got published in 2019 as a as
a regional approach and this was some of
the data that came out now you know when
you look at this Sean you know you see
untreated places like Connecticut where
I live in Fairfax Virginia down where
you are you don't spray seed head
suppression in Utah you get tons of seed
heads but you come out to where I am now
out in Oregon and it seemed like you
don't get as many seed heads or they
weren't measuring as many through this
process now I was talking about it's so
funny I was talking to Brian McDonald
yesterday who's just doing some of this
work they're finding out here the
February application seems to lock it in
like your late season application so can
you talk a little bit uh first off why
is fall working is that when the flowers
getting uh initiated and you're holding
it down there or are you stopping
initiation well you think about the
genetic variability in Polo right and
how many uh biotypes phenotypes that are
out there
so some of them are going to air towards
sensitivity to winter warming you get a
warm spell in the winter some of those
poor plants are going to kick-start what
we call evocation you know that what the
decision is made by the plant to produce
a flower now the speed in the winter is
so slow it's going to take that plant
weeks to to develop the tissue needed to
actually start to push that seed head
out but that decision that which is
hormonal based inside the plant
on some power it will be made just
because of a few warm days in the winter
on other plants they're going to wait
until a stronger push in the spring so
traditionally we've gone after those
spring plants but never really realizing
that there's a lot of these
quote-unquote decisions being made
through the winter and if we just back
up an additional application we can
catch most of those plants and I believe
this Regional variability has to do with
variability in phenotypes or biotypes
across the regions you get more
perennial polar you're going to have
less seed heads to start with and and
you know another thing that really
probably factors into this and I'm going
out on thin ice here because there's not
a lot of research to support this uh
comment but I we often see much stronger
effects of products like proxy or
ethafone based products at our
University Research sites then we do
on-golf courses that have used those
products for 15 years running and I do
believe there's varying levels of
tolerance to the product because it's
hey it's a cdet suppressor we're weeding
out the most susceptible individuals on
those golf courses and the plants that
remain it's probably going to take a
little more aggressive approach or
you're not going to be quite as
effective so we do get a lot of any seed
and suppression work you do no matter
where it is you're going to see
variability temporally and spatially and
I think it has to do to all that genetic
variability but the you know backing up
into the winter and putting that early
app I think what it's doing is
addressing the proportion of individuals
that would have made the decision
earlier where we're blocking them as
well because that's what does it's a it
produces a lot of ethylene in the plant
and that's a hormonal suppressor of the
decision to make a seed head and you
know now this has been out there for a
number of years now I mean it's pretty
standard guys are putting this out with
the snow mold applications uh
particularly in Northern climates
um has have you seen a downside to it
last week when I was up at that walk and
talk he double covers those greens and
he's got power greens has their yeah I'm
wondering if there's any downside to
suppressing being Undercovers uh uh more
damage from Ice I haven't heard anything
have you I I have heard of some it takes
some pretty you know in extreme places
where you're already biting nails over
losing Poe annual to Winter stress in
those areas I would I I can't tell you
to what degree I don't think it's a a
huge massive magnitude of effect from
methophon but it's not helping you it's
not helping you preserve the survival of
those power plants that you don't want
to check out on your timeline you know
that on any other timeline than your own
and so yeah I do think that there's a
little bit of added stress to the power
I haven't seen any evidence of added
enough added stress to Bent that we're
actually concerned over winter kill
event but
um so I would say it's a small effect
but it's a real effect that under
extreme conditions these early apps or
these winter programs can increase the
possibility of Poa mortality during the
winter well because there's no doubt
like we were walking around Carl and I
were walking around a black core screens
at Bethpage last week and you know they
have make a fall app and they had made
their spring app based on on the models
and you can see the pole is regulated
and in fact the bent was sort of you
know growing up and and not regulated as
much and you see that a lot at this time
I think people forget oh it's a seed
head suppression and they forget it's
you know it's a growth regulator so and
and they differentially uh regulates
growth right in some ways that sort of
the nature of how herbicides work right
24d really pounds the stimulation of the
broad leaves and not the others now
since I brought up herbicides we were
very excited I don't think we got the
chat last year so we'll catch up now
we're very excited about this being
registered in New York state and I just
want to make sure everybody understands
some of the p's and q's about using this
but I'll start out I grabbed some slides
from a presentation you gave a while ago
just to set you up here today one is
poke here actually does some seed head
suppression
um and I'm curious is this a different
control program uh than you use for the
spring and the fall Sean tell me how you
think about POA cure albeit a fairly
expensive seat head suppression product
uh what did you find when you looked at
this for seed head suppression well I
you know it it suppresses seed heads in
a way that's kind of similar to the way
Embark or fluid I'd use to suppress it
it damages the polar plant thus kind of
setting it back and therefore you know
having a in most cases a massive impact
on overall seed head numbers as soon as
the plant starts to shake off the damage
and grow again if the season is still
there it'll start putting on seed ads as
quickly as it can so it's not really a
long-term it doesn't work in the way
that ethipine does hormonal suppression
of the decision it damages the plant so
much that the plant's working on this
other stuff that it's got to fix and it
really literally doesn't have the energy
to make a seed Edge the way I would
describe it but no I would say good our
biggest concern regarding that seated
suppression arena is balancing our
airification event in conjunction with a
pole cure program which again the
program is going to be much more geared
toward polar control than it is seated
suppression yeah that's right and that I
was just set you up for it because what
you said is interesting you get that
sort of shock to the plant and that's
why I think sometimes wedding agents
work they sort of burn and shock the
plant and as soon as and then that seems
to suppress them at least for a little
while so you know you're saying boom you
get a hit from this product but as of
course we both know the Elegance of this
thing is it kills very slowly now I want
to make sure because I know there's a
spring and fall and I know they've gone
to a distribution model now uh where
they're selling it out through sales
folks where they were controlling it a
little bit more can we go over the way
you think about a spring program versus
a fall program if you're really
interested in embarking upon uh using
pole cure to transition Your Greens to
more perennial grasses yeah so fall
programs are much more powerful than
spring programs the standard is five
applications in a year this would be to
uh quote unquote renovate or to
eliminate POA from a green and uh the
the goal is to dial it back dial the
power of the product back the rates are
designed to to deliver a one to two year
uh effective control of Poa and that's a
hard peel for most people to swallow but
the reason is is that with variable
environmental conditions and and polar
populations if you get any more
aggressive than that then a lot of
people are going to be left holding you
know that uh pitted Turf surface bag you
know they're going to be they're going
to be left they're going to be screwed
basically because they've compromised
the revenue source of the course and you
can't have that we can deal with baby
yellow uh uh POA we can you know
because we've got colorants we we can
deal with many things well you can even
deal with compromised putting surfaces
with top dressing to an extent but all
of this stuff comes at a cost and and
so anyway that we're trying to they we
the researchers and they the company
have kind of come to a decision to to to
Dow back the aggressiveness of this
program so two apps in the fall that's
where you normally get your Keel three
apps in the spring the goal there is to
suppress further expansion of the Polar
if you start in the spring what you're
doing is where normally you would peek
and spring at a maybe a 50 to 60 percent
cover on your greens
whole care treatments in conjunction
with that or pulling that down to maybe
your Peak at 30 percent cover and you'll
see a lot of discoloration some other
stuff but you're not really getting
death of the pole at that point then
summer conditions come in and kind of
keep the plant in check and then next
fall it'll start to rebound and then
when we get on the treatment programs
going into winter
we kill the plants most of them and and
you'll if you're at a green that's uh as
high percentage of what I said I know a
lot of you folks are yeah they're going
to come out of that next season with
some pitting and some compromised
surface that you're going to have to be
dealing with but the goal is the spring
programs reduce the overall population
level so that it mitigates the intensity
of the damage when we start killing the
plants next fall and into the winter so
that's kind of how it's designed uh it
doesn't always work that way and you
have to be on your p's and q's with
colorants and and top dressing another
thing is a lot of people get into this
debate about you know when should I
verify and how do I balance when to
apply the products around airification
and remember hey you don't have to
verify this year if you're literally
renovate the greens from Poe annual you
know we can skip one year
your lips to God's ears
and then the other one is at the font
ethiphon has a negative interaction with
Polo cure what we've seen is that um it
it can
airification or some type of mechanical
injury event or heat stress at the fine
can cause the plants it can increase the
uh their response to that environment
and when public here is and one of the
big things that epiphon will do we
believe is it causes uh heightened root
senescence and if that happens while a
pull-a-cure program is underway
the roots that normally would regenerate
quickly can't do so because they're
coming back from the crown there's pole
cure up there so until that product
starts to dissipate and as long as
you're putting out repeat apps those
roots can't regenerate same is true if
you're in the middle of a poker program
and you come in and do a massive
airification with a really aggressive
top dressing and and uh a lot of
physical injury shocks the plant
the plant loses roots and normally one
week later you're back in business with
those roots but if whole care is in
place you won't be and so we don't see
surface evidence of that typically but
if you start digging around while you're
on a pulcure program and you're out
there tickling the green weekly or
you're doing needle tiling and you're
top dressing and these things that a lot
of people normally do in their
maintenance program to keep the the
highest quality greens
those things interact negatively with
the Poetry program because normally you
don't see this happening underground but
you're shocking the roots and they're
rebounding and you know overall it's a
stimulant for the plant you've got
beautiful greens when you're doing these
um mechanical
uh uh treatments but when you throw a
poker in the mix you're messing with the
ability of the plant to fluctuate those
root Dynamics and it's best to just stay
away from those potentially injurious
physical treatments while you're on a
public Care Program okay so what you're
this is very interesting it's so it's
really nice that the thinking has
evolved in on this Sean it sounds like
it it was like okay you do it and it
happens and now it's like you got to
take your time because we've learned
there are more situations where it
doesn't work as well or there's more
damage than we'd expected it's
interacting with more things than we had
expected so I mean honestly if if you've
had a lot of problems with winter damage
which is I think why this conversation's
gotten more common especially in the
north and and you know you got 50 50 or
70 percent with 30 percent increase you
know you you know you you've had it and
you can't regress this is and I don't
want to say a poor man's option because
it isn't cheap but it's actually cheaper
than you know rebuilding the whole
things if the soils are working you're
saying it's a year to two and that but
that doesn't mean you can't have good
greens it just means you've just got to
be a little bit more mindful that when
you impose stress it could have a more
dramatic effect
right yeah I mean Park here when when it
starts to regulate the POA and the pole
goes off color putting speeds actually
increase and like you said Frank it's a
very slow acting product it takes 30
plus days before you start to actually
get mortality of the poem and that's 30
days that you can grow bent because it's
not slowing the vent down and so now
that works great on a 15 20 pull
infestation but on a 60 70 percent
co-infestation that's not enough time to
cover that much area and so at some
point some suffering is going to happen
uh it arguably it's it's less suffering
than a renovation but but some suffering
is going to happen so go into it knowing
that if you're that high of a population
level and and you know the company won't
even sell you enough product to do your
whole course unless you've already
bought enough for a demonstration and
even even due to distribution they
maintain that policy you have to sign a
waiver if you haven't already done
testing on course they like literally
they're telling you oh you want to buy a
pallet no you know I'd love to take your
money but we're not going to take your
money this is what you need to do this
is what we recommend and so uh you know
and but they'll still allow you to do it
you just have to sign a waiver if you've
never evaluated the product on course
you have to sign a waiver to buy enough
to do everything okay so let's look at
the other end and then and then we'll
see if there's questions the other end
is a lot of guys got new Bank Grass
screens
um they got some you know uh POA coming
in I'm starting to tell people listen
you put new bench grass Greens in you
probably could get by a couple years
with manual stuff depending on the
design and how they're working out just
poking and plot prodding then I would
say the next level might be dabbing or
spot treating with something like Polo
cure uh maybe even trim it on the end of
a dab could work as well when manual
can't keep up but when you know when
you're starting to have when you're
starting to lose right you before I even
use poetry I'd probably say listen this
area it can't grow good grass the poet
keeps coming in let's fix this thing I
try to keep poker in my pocket as long
as I could but know that I don't want to
let it get north of five six ten percent
if I want to use Polo cure to really to
be transparent right so that there isn't
pain and that's possible Right Sean so
how much power do you how long will you
let it go in these new greens before you
start a program where it's more than
just dabbing so I so in the year of
establishment I recommend not using uh
pre-emerge type products anyway
if you're growing it in aggressively
then and if you start clean then you
shouldn't really have like you said
Frank you won't have serious problems
until later on because people are moving
it in it's coming in through a number of
ways but if you start clean
and that's how you need to do this you
you don't want to be using herbicides in
the year of establishment but after that
first year of establishment my opinion
is a really good way to use pull a cure
uh most people are familiar with their
pgr program stay on those pgr programs
but supplement that with one spring
application at 500 grams the 0.6 rate
and one fall application and that gives
you a very powerful residual component
to to what you've always been doing and
that'll take our you know six year
transition from renovation to oh crap
we've got power problems and it could
turn if you manage it well it could turn
it into 12 plus years you know boy
wouldn't it be nice that our Renovations
are based only on variety improvements
and and not that's right losing the
battle to Poland but I think that's one
way to do it is
um within the first couple years go on
and just supplement what you're doing
with dabbing or with those just the
spring fall program which is you know
just those two apps in a year is far
less than a pgr program and total costs
it's not quite as costly as the five app
per year you know so it's interesting um
all right now listen we didn't get to
the uh cryogenic and the and the weights
and I didn't get to that drone works I
might bug you again oh man in the next
couple of weeks to get you back on the
other show because that stuff is cool
we've got some crazy cool stuff you've
got some fun right now
I mean the cryogenic stuff is uh every
time I keep looking at it it's looking
better and better just imagine a golf
course where you have robots that can
dock to a
a liquid air machine on your course
taking your air turning it into liquid
air putting it into a robot and then the
robot's going out and spot treating
plants and you get a better
environmental profile than I borrowed
air for a little while made it cold
killed weeds with it then I put it back
into the air only if it's solar powered
robot well I I'm working on that I'm
actually using one that I haven't
tweeted on we're using solar collectors
we're using parabolic mirrors to
concentrate sunlight to kill weeds so
we see this Sean we see this in New York
City right um there's a couple of uh
Turf areas I've worked on in New York
City even lawn roofs where they're
putting that glass that helps the birds
not run into it it really transmits heat
down and they've started to see impacts
on Turf quality it's part of the heat
island effect as well it's so fast
enough I've got uh with one small mirror
about 12 inch diameter I can melt less
than 15 seconds so it but you know a
human can't do it but a robot can direct
those things where the Precision needed
either that of course of course there's
a combustion issue with that so what I'm
looking at is I'm using the uh parabolic
mirror to heat a probe and then the
probe is being stuck into the weed and
so it honestly it's more of a marketing
um Advantage than it is biological in
terms of the solar collection uh my
backup is going to be butane for the
probe uh making sure that these robots
can always work because we get cloudy
days and yeah for sure yeah we've got
some really fun ideas going uh in that
area this is great listen we gotta go
because we're past the time but I can't
now we've teased everybody Sean because
it's too interesting because as a wheat
scientist I'm so pleased to see you work
on these Alternatives because you and I
know herbicides are are now on some sort
of expiration date with not a lot of new
chemistry coming if we don't start
thinking about this now when those
things stop working in another 15 or 20
years we're not going to have anything
so these things that sound goofy are
going to be pretty practical uh
goofy things I'm telling you all right
people are backed into a corner right
you know that they need other options
100 Sean great thanks for taking the
time during your vacation I hope you get
a hole in one on the Putt-Putt yeah yeah
thanks a bunch yeah we'll get Sean back
to the Putt-Putt course novel weed
control strategies go follow Sean on
Twitter he's got a lot of cool stuff
like he said he's tweeting about the
drones and the cryogenic stuff I'll go
give him the follow uh we'll be back
again tomorrow with uh Dr Aaron Patton
from Purdue uh chatting about a lot of
landscape stuff uh until then take it
easy everybody all right this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu